we live shouting
we love baby baby
what's happening
hot breath live we out here i'm comedian
joel byers
i am comedian yoshi in the building
oh that's quite a last name you got
there is that a family name is that
mr in the building mr yoshi in the
building
my mama called me that's what my daddy
called me my grandpa called me
mr yoshi in the building well we out
here welcome back to hot breath live
every tuesday we on here breaking down
comedy specials
and
giving y'all joke feedback as well um
this is the four comics by comics
channel we've given you that inside
insight you can't get anywhere else from
the industry from working comedians
we're just out here blowing smoke we
ain't just out here
talking about specials without watching
them i ain't throwing shade last week we
talked about kat williams special which
if you haven't heard there's a separate
clip of it on our youtube channel
you can watch that or you can watch the
full live stream on our youtube channel
but yeah
there was another channel out there
talking about cat williams
you ain't even watch it
were they talking about cat williams or
ali sadiq
oh cat williams
we're talking about ali sadiq today
but but they they ain't even seen it
ain't synced it name is sent it they
just they just going they just trying to
catch a wave fam they just out here on
some clout chase
which is fine
it's got plenty of views it's got more
views than we got so maybe there's
something to that
maybe there's something too
let's just talk comedy without doing
comedy that's a good idea
that's a good idea
oh this is great oh we already got
people in here yo we got tony baloney we
got dc rants
we got comic lee funny jordan wilson in
here
tony baloney that's such a great name
this is a
oh oh and apparently that uh tony knows
uh dc rants
so this is gonna be dope oh we out here
hop rather verse good to see all y'all
so
let's get into it i mean should we jump
right in i don't know what um
i mean we got the
i mean we could jump right into it i
mean
first of all i mean i will say just off
the rip
ali sadiq is probably
one of my favorite working comedians at
the moment like
off of just
off of watching his career i don't
remember watching him
he had a special with like had something
with like bill bellamy way back in the
day
i think it was like they were like on a
road trip and they were just like
talking and i was like who is this dude
right and this was before i even
thought about doing comedy and then
years later like years into doing comedy
i got to see him
like work
and i was blown away
by the version that i was seeing like in
youtube videos versus the live version
mm-hmm
and it was incredible to watch
like
master chef
level
comedy
and the comfort level
that he was on stage
and it felt
so
easy he made comedy look like it was
just
he's just saying words
and people are just laughing as if
though like i mean but you know that
obviously there's work involved
um
but man this special
odd out on youtube called domino effect
is the shiznitz it is yeah it is yeah it
is
yeah it's so good yeah
i feel bad i feel bad we didn't um
people are still coming in here i i
don't i didn't want to jump the gun on
them
but um
we jumped right in both you and i are
both super excited about this special
maybe we should play the trailer for
them just to give them a taste if they
haven't seen it just a little context
because we do got peeps still rolling in
josh ward said what's up fellas dubs
general
said uh i've seen that set before and it
was different every time yeah um
i've seen it before too
yeah i think um
he came to the punch line i wouldn't
watch him at the punch line but reggie
who like runs sound at punchline told me
every set was different he said he did
six shows that weekend and every single
show was different
and they all killed
i watched two of the shows
and he did like an hour 10.
um
all different
all different
yeah here's the thing i heard parts of
this special
in between those two
hours
was obvious that he was working on
something
but just his prolificness
when it comes to
the amount of time that he has
is such a
but then also the swag to be like i'm
gonna run six different
hours
on a weekend
you know what i'm saying like yeah
it's another level tony baloney said who
are the 103 people that disliked his
special
hilarious
haters hilarious so let's uh let's play
the trailer for people if they haven't
seen if you have the trailer is still it
gives you a dope overview of it
and um
also subscribe to this channel if you're
not and while we are playing this
trailer share this youtube live video
hit the like button let that algorithm
show them some love so we can get in the
rhythm of that algo
and then share this video we're trying
to hit 50 000 subs this year and you
sharing it is gonna help us do that but
as you do that oh let me bring yoshi in
here there he is
let's play the trailer
this is the beginning of my
street pharmaceutical life
so it's 1983
i'm 10 years old
this is where i find out my daddy sells
cocaine
i friend james got on gun holsters and
ain't nobody got no shirt on though but
they got on gun hoses
i'm saying boy this is a gangster game
of monopoly they playing
[Music]
my daddy
said
you scared it pulls out
a two shot
there
black and white pearl ham he's saying
now he'll if somebody come in the house
you know what to do i said no i do not
know what to do
who you been talking to they told you i
know what to do
i am 10. i
[Applause]
see the reason why i tell my stories the
way i tell them because see
people they glorify the [ __ ]
i'ma tell you
the hard [ __ ] that happened so these
young boys know hey man you can get into
the [ __ ] you want to just know some [ __ ]
gonna happen to you
you know i turn around it's a lady
standing there i'm like hey how you
doing
she punched me to goddamn job
so i pushed over the [ __ ] what you
doing
and then the dude jump on me and i'm
fighting both i'm like i'm fighting the
goddamn dopey couple out here
you can't lose no mode
this is a matter of life
[Applause]
oh my gosh so there it is there is the
trailer
and um for those of you that don't know
it's available on his youtube channel
now
but
bruh that tells it all right there
basically his story
of how he got into drug dealing at the
age of 10
and it gives you a good deep like a good
taste of
his storytelling style i mean it is show
don't tell that comedy writing rule
of showing and not telling he shows it
just in a way that's so raw and
authentic and funny
by the way and funny knock dead funny
yeah i think
so it's funny because i feel like ali
sadiq has had these like career moments
a little bit
whereas like the last time he blew was
mexican on boots
and when you go watch mexican on boots
and you listen to that story
everything about that story is so
detailed
like
so much detail
to it
and the details that he tells you
puts you literally in the position of
where he was as he's going through all
of this and that's
why he's so prolific his style of
bringing you in
and that's the other thing about allah
sadiq
very different than earthquake
yes ali
takes his ever loving time yep you are
not going to rush
anything he says
and i love that it's such a comfort
level
just like i think in watching him in
atlanta
as he sits down on this chair
it's about 15 seconds
for him to say
anything
and he's just him getting comfortable
in the chair just like just a little bit
of wiggle
just like
you mean yeah
and then like his first words away
hey
how y'all doing
yeah he did that in his comedy central
special too and then he just goes into
this but like just goes into the store
and it's like
yo just that level of just
like
i'mma do me
is so
like it's
it's so incredibly talented it's such a
different level of talent
and it also is
not just like the details he uses but
then in this special it's such a good
presentation of just
he says the details but then like he
said like fighting the dope fiends he's
like physically fighting the dope fiends
like he is showing you
what he's talking about not only with
his words where you paint the picture
but physically as well which is like
two different as we break down these
specials you know we look at like the
writing and the personal aspect of it
but also the performing aspect of it
where he is like yeah he sits down
but he can be just as big on stage like
as as he is sitting down he can bring it
up physically moving around the stage i
think even that that part of it the fact
that he sits down
moves and then goes back and sits down
shows you the level of comfort that he
is with his story
like he's like this is a sit down
portion of the story nope this is let me
get up and show you portion
of the story
and what i like about that is that
you could tell that like
he is what you think
when you think like a funny family
member
it's the embodiment of ali sadiq ali
sadiq is that funny family member or
like that old uncle that you've got that
be telling just wild stories yeah
he's literally the embodiment of
every uncle that everyone has that you
know has been through some [ __ ] you know
he's seen some stuff
right like he's got like
one leg like he's got just stories or
he's got like you know like a scar
you're like where do you get that girl
let me tell you the story next thing you
know you're sitting down for another 30
minutes as your uncle tells you the
story but just
uh somebody said he's definitely bill
cosby yes he's like bill cosby is titus
like a lot of people that are very much
but
he does storytelling in today's day
like nobody else and it's so different
than
what you think comedy is going
because comedy is so like
i would say comedy is very much like
short
uh what's the word
like attention span yeah and it's like
it's like mark norman sam morell
i mean even earthquake who
his special inspired this entire show we
do now and we're actually gonna
review ali's special on the earthquake
scale that we started last week
but earthquake is boom boom boom boom
boom boom but ali is
smooth it's like jazz
but it pays off the pops the lap
a few times i was like oh well that's a
different laugh
you know what i mean you're like that is
a house laugh like
he is murdering but on his pace
yeah
yeah yeah there were
i counted like
there were maybe like
eight to ten moments
where
even the crowd couldn't stop themselves
like they were laughing and he had to
like wait for them to finish laughing
you don't say like you're like
like because he didn't like i don't
think he even realized how funny the
thing was
because they still laughed even after
like it died down because it was that
good of a joke you know i'm saying it
was like yeah or his facial expression
or he would get a laugh just on a look
you know
which i took a screenshot of this facial
expression i mean this thing just killed
me
that's that's quintessential ali
siddique right there
[Music]
it's so good but yeah let's get into the
numbers i'm sorry i cut off your
analysis there oh somebody said what's
written on the wall uh it's intentional
present grateful and laugh
it's just the way that i think about my
days i just try to be intentional try to
be present
try to be grateful and then laugh at it
but yeah that's what's on my wall um
so the numbers
uh
it's an hour the special itself is an
hour 20 minutes
but the end of it he actually does a
little bit like it's almost like a
blooper reel or just like another
version of a
part of the set so it's actually kind of
cool just to watch a different version
of that um so the entire special is an
hour 15 minutes so it's 75 minutes long
and he had 405 laughs
and at that pace that's five and a half
laughs a minute
now
that five and a half laughs a minute at
his pace
it's not like he's getting laughs really
per minute
they're like
eight to ten spots where this dude
literally gets laughs like every single
word that comes out of his mouth like it
was like it was just like bam bam damn
damn big pop
again bam bam bam like
the laughs are staggered around in the
special
but they're staggered in the right
places it was incredible to watch
like
like
what i what i really like about it is he
told you what was about to happen and
then showed you
and then you still laughed at it mm-hmm
and when we talk about laughs some of
these are long laughs too this isn't
like
it's like
yeah
they're like tidal waves of laughter
waves of life um and one of my favorite
things
about this
is
the first three sentences of the special
literally set you up for the entire show
yes
i mean it was so good it was just like
it's almost like it was like a
scientific research it was just like i'm
gonna tell you this thing
and it's gonna affect everything else
that i say from here on out but just
what it was itself was just a good
observation
about his own like
i just recognized this thing about
what happened in my life
and i'ma tell you a little bit about it
and how i got there
and then
hour 15 into the story it was so well
done
yeah it's like you said before maybe
before the show is like you can see the
you can see the movie like this is
literally like
it's like a movie that he's telling us
in like a three-act structure
that is hilarious
hilarious yeah yeah i mean
like so the numbers you said it was
basically an hour 20 and he was it's an
hour 15 minutes
the special says it's about 20. but
there's about five minutes in the
beginning at the end sorry right that's
like a repeat of another story right
yeah that's true yeah after the credits
yeah it's almost like after the credits
like the marvel thing to do
um
but yeah 405 laughs
uh
within that whole thing and uh i counted
the pops there were about
nine pops
of just huge
laughs like just big
like i mean what i would think to be
applause breaks but just where he had to
like stop before going on because it was
just that well
executed of jokes
but yeah yeah house laughs as we call it
in the biz
you'll get there young gun you'll get
there we call those house laughs
i think my favorite part about this
special is how specific
everything was he left no detail
unturned
and what i like about ali siddique is
like he's also not afraid to put names
to everything that's what i liked about
that mexican with boots i still remember
anybody know cece you know cece
it's like this is specifically
like
cece is the guy that you go call
who's got the knife in jail like
i remember that like vividly of how
funny him just going around you know
you see
just but like it's that style but yeah
the specificity that he uses in his
storytelling is magical and he says in
the special that he uses real names
because all of these are true stories
so he's like you can ask them this he's
like all this is true and that's how
he's able to use real names
oh that's so good
so
this is the moment everyone's been
waiting on now
this is it's time
to do
what is the on the earthquake scale on
the earthquake scale i mean of one out
of five earthquakes
on the earthquake scale this is a
certified
uh
five out of five earthquakes yes this
question
is
like legitimately the definition this is
the definition for any comic who's like
oh i'm a storyteller yes this is the
storyteller special if you ever be like
oh i'm a storyteller i tell long stories
i don't have any jokes or i can't write
all these jokes from my story boo
yeah
watch this special
yep and then yeah
restyle of this special
that's yeah
i i couldn't agree more you know uh we
started this last week with the cat
williams
special and you and i had different
ratings uh but this one you know
i couldn't agree more it's i think it's
i think it's five out of five a hundred
percent and
i i try to go into these reviews
unbiased you know i want to watch it as
a working professional comedian i'm i'm
a fan of cat williams last week you know
and i i gave him three out of five
earthquakes you know so
i i like to be subjective about these
separating the kind of me being a fan of
this comic from the work
this
is another
level like it it's it's up there with
the earthquake special like earthquakes
is like 35 minutes we said you know his
boom boom boom boom this one hour 15
and it it does not disappoint there's no
lulls wow
it's at ali sadiq's pace yes right yeah
his earthquake
just is a fast-paced comedian yep right
so he's going to give you man
it's like a boxing match kind of thing
yeah
it's an earthquake it's a natural
disaster it's like this is a sit down oh
we about to have a good time like
like i watch i watch the special three
times
to your point
first of all
first one was just like just let me
watch it just as a casual fan
second was i watched it as a comedian
like i try to find the jokes i try to
find where certain things were if i
could see things coming and then i
watched it a third time like
as a specialist i was like i got like
deep into like the joke structure
it didn't disappoint even the third time
through i was laughing at the same stuff
all the way through because of how
detailed
and just organic all his stories were it
was so good such a good start it's it's
it's a comedy it's a masterpiece in my
opinion it's someone who's been doing
comedy
at a high level for a long time it's i
mean it's kind of like earthquake where
earthquakes had some things
but that chappelle special that he
produced like kind of put him on the map
for a lot of people i think i hope this
special does the same overnight success
exactly
exactly
exactly so five out of five earthquakes
yeah for mr ali sadiq without a doubt
no way
yeah like
originality
no one's ever gonna be able to tell that
story
the stage presence was like magical he
didn't
he moved all over the place like he's
not even like he's not like a like a
sebastian where he's just like arms or
anything like that
he slowed it down but then
like the fighting scenes and like god my
favorite line
was when he when he was talking about
the guy who threw him in the dumpster
and he goes and he goes to the other guy
he was like yeah i do threw me in a
dumpster too i was
and that i love
i love it when comics aren't afraid to
be silly you know ali is a scary dude
and if anyone has seen my interviews
with him in both interviews i've done
with ali
there have been both moments where i've
been like you're scaring me because like
i'm alone in a hotel room with this guy
and i'm like he could literally kill me
right now and not even think twice about
it and that that's it like there's
he has a presence about him that is so
like assured yes someone
who doesn't take any [ __ ] like part of
my french but like he's just not he's
not a guy to be messed with like
he is so co but he's also so comfortable
with himself and who he is
but also like
at the core of it
he's just like a regular everyday dude
that's been through some [ __ ] that loves
telling these stories yeah and i also
love the fact that he's also very much
like
one of those people who's like no just
do what you want to do
just do you more than anything else
because he was i mean i remember in that
interview that you did he was like man i
don't care about last per minute
he'd hate that we have the number on
this yeah he really would he really
would and yeah he goes in on like he's a
purist when it comes to comedy like he
talks about in the in the podcast about
like if he's like if you have a sitcom i
guarantee your stand-up sucks like he he
says
stuff like that where he's like he's a
purist funny first
like in a very real way of coming from a
real place so
five out of five comics it's a must
watch
and um for people that have seen it i'd
love to see what maybe what your rating
would be out of five for the people that
are watching this right now we both gave
it five out of five but we'd love to see
your opinion and
what's um
five out of five so
there it is
there it is five out of five earthquakes
the first of its kind
we have not given a five out of five
earthquakes yet but
this is the first
so
yeah i agree
so our next segment will get more into a
storytelling but uh part of what we do
here of course is we love we're comics
helping comics so we do like to do joke
feedback
on here as well
so we'll do a joke feedback and then
we're going to break down one of ali's
stories from the special
um and show you guys how you can start
to tell stories like ali said well maybe
we will say like ollie's a d you can
learn from what he does and make it your
own but you're not ollie sadiq um
just watch just watch the special and
he'll he'll answer that question for you
but
let's do um
let's do a little joke let's do the joke
feedback it looks like the first one i'm
seeing here
is from
um jordan wilson yay
brethren
jordan wilson all right so his joke i
have one of those faces that startle
people
seeing my face is like finding out
you're pregnant people don't respond
well if they're not expecting it
i like it i feel like it could go a
little deeper
with like maybe just one more tag of
exactly
what
like it's almost like you have to give
an example
of not responding well if they're not
expecting it
like i feel like it's missing a tag to
make the punch line pop
yeah i think just don't respond oh and i
didn't do a countdown timer on this one
there we go
we're going to remember this one day
yoshi
but um
i also think that
people don't respond well if they're not
expecting it i think you could be more
specific there to make that line more
punchy so instead of not respond well
it's like how do people respond when
they're pregnant they're shocked
they're angry they're offended they want
to kill it immediately you know it's
like
something more specific that has more of
a punch to it beyond they don't respond
well well how don't they respond well
you know more specific there raise the
stakes
for sure yeah that's a good point i was
thinking
they're like
i was thinking i was just starting to
think of pregnant and
when people are pregnant especially when
women are pregnant they have cravings
so do they look at his face and be like
oh i want to eat something now but they
don't they look away from him oh they
get morning sickness
yeah they get morning sickness yeah
yo that's it
that's it
that was it awesome
very nice
i'm with that one i don't hate that joke
actually
that's solid
yeah see my face is like finding out oh
that's funny don't that's it
all right
oh and uh tony baloney said i'm gonna
watch
sadiq special like i just hit puberty
and it's debbie does dallas
and dub said i still i used to tell
jokes punchline setup i met ali asked
him for a few pointers now i tell
stories i used to just oh yeah he became
my mentor now i tell stories
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think billy i had
billy sorel's on the show he said the
same thing both houston comics who ali
he actually shot it in houston as well
um i think at the houston improv based
on the credits he thanked houston improv
so i'm thinking he shot it there
but um oh good and jordan's still
watching nice he said thanks out the
morning sickness idea
yay
that's very funny jordan all right
so let's let's get into it we would we
kind of we got to tease this but let's
actually get into ollie's sadiq's
storytelling style i mean we had other
topics planned but like when i watched
it i was like yo we got to do all these
like this man hit another level with
this special and i'm not surprised
either i mean he's legitimately one of
the best and has been one of the best
but um
just to see it in
so beautiful and inspiring and
disheartening as well all at the same
time of like oh that's how good comedy
can be
kind of like watching the earthquake
special and you're like oh
that's what comedy is
so the uh the first thing to get into
ali's storytelling i do want to play
this clip from the podcast we did with
him
just him
telling how he tells a story just to
kind of give you a little context for
where his mindset is around telling this
telling a compelling story so here we go
and just the flex that he's been on the
show twice but don't worry about that
so it's just the
the putting it and seeing it and piecing
it together and being able to tell it
very fluid from
beginning
to end
with
no real
point
it's no punch line it's no
i don't i'm not writing punch lines in
it
i'm
telling the story
first
and then i start thinking about the
parts that could be funny
but as i'm telling the story i'm telling
the dry story
and it goes back to
when you're not being funny
be interesting because whatever you say
that's interesting eventually turn funny
because you jovial anyway
so i'm telling the story
and then it gets to these
pieces of
when people be like oh [ __ ]
and then you list you looking at the
audience and you see them like
yeah
they're leaning in so
boom
getting the audience to lean in by being
interesting first so his storytelling
style is literally
say the story as it happened
and then go back and add the funny to it
yeah like even in this special i just
remember when he talks about him and his
sister of how she said
you know mama's house has amenities
and how he used that later on
amenities yeah that's just great because
like it's such a like a specific word
it's so specific to think about
amenities at your parents house and you
never really think of like your own
house as having amenities but because he
was living with his mom versus his dad
it's like huh mom's house has amenities
and just that reminder just that little
one piece of it was so funny to me of
like huh i guess we do have laundry and
uh regular amenities that you have to
think about in the house with such a
funny like specific
detail that i thought was so important
to the story just that his mom's house
had amenities every yeah every word
paints a picture and that's why
literally every word counts like every
every single word matters and stand up
and it can really be the difference
between a laugh and a lull it really can
so
the fact even he is like yeah tell the
story dry but then i go back and add the
funny so many comics are like well i'm a
storyteller so i don't i don't really
have punch lines but it's ironic and
creative because i'm a storyteller it's
like nah
ali shows you right there you can be a
storyteller and still
murder
murder
murder
oh this is oh michelle said her
storytelling is i start with the end
first
nice and then andy gunning said i become
a storyteller by accident with this
waxed hamster bit
oh my god i heard it uh this weekend it
was hilarious
oh yeah yeah yeah and andy gunnins yeah
yeah seen it
like the long version and then he
shortened it into
a five minute bit it was freaking
hilarious it was so good was that the
world series of comedy that you you
killed is that the one you're talking
about
that's when you saw it yeah yeah yeah
out there representing the hopper at the
verse murdering these festivals yeah
yeah yeah yeah anyone's out there too so
was stephen peters steve peterson hey
i love you getting that
yeah man
so let's
brethren's out there
i love hearing that and let's um let's
watch one of his stories from the
special what do you think do you want to
like kind of know how we know he tells a
story i think it's good for comics to
see it in action now that they've heard
the context of how he creates a story
how stories are written
where a lot of the time and i heard this
i heard christopher titus say this um
not on the podcast yet chris
um
no no actually we actually dm'd on
twitter he said he would do it but i
i i can't even tell you how many people
said they're gonna do it and then
haven't but also i can't tell you how
many people i've done the same thing too
so um
[Laughter]
but anyway
so uh
this was one of my i really enjoyed this
story there's so many great stories but
this is the one of his this is like his
first time dealing drugs so i think it's
a good kind of teaser for the special
for you to want to get further into it
but this is really kind of his uh
10 year old
uh what is it coming out party as a as
he says a pharmaceutical street
rep so here we go
i know i know people thinking well i
ain't really just heard nothing that bad
just yet about your daddy your daddy
just seemed like a
normal delusional bachelor
so okay
been living with this man a little bit
and
i'm asleep
the pacing
the
man comes in this is like about the
third month end
of this man about three months
this was the really the first sign that
i just went on home
that man walked in my room
really it was his weight room that he
turned into my room
walked into my room
and said hey
i'm sleep 12 30
in the am the man say say hello look
here
you you sleep
i said i said yeah what's up he said man
look here
i'm about to go out of town
[Laughter]
man i i got to go to school and watch it
i know you got to go to school
i said i'm going downtown
so so what what am i what
[Music]
do i walk you to school in the morning i
said no you said so go to school eat you
some fruit oats where you go
eat some food
[Laughter]
i said
you leaving me here though
but you scared i said yes
i ain't never been down for myself
before what's wrong with you
my daddy
said i you scared and pulls out
a two-shot
derivative
black and white pearl handle he's saying
now here if somebody come in the house
you know what to do i said no i do not
know what you do
who you been talking to that told you i
know what to do
i am ten i do not know what to do
you say now look
that's all preliminary i got some other
things i need you to do
now
it's going to be
it's gonna be fifteen dollars
get their money
go upstairs you get the stuff
get that to them close the door lock it
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
so it's about 12 35 he's gone
i'm thinking
my daddy playing
is crap
you know don't been cracking all night
so i gotta go to school tomorrow i'm up
in time going to school
i'm at school
i'm
sleeping
i get sent to the office for sleeping in
class
i get home my daddy
is sitting at the table
from the school
talking about you being sleeping class
i said i don't know if you check your
little box upstairs
but your little box is full of money
because the dough
[Applause]
i should've
the detail the physicality the pacing
the timing like it all just
really good
such a good story and his facial
expressions yes get in so many laughs
yes certainly laughs throughout the
entire special his facial expressions
were just like
magical yeah even that like just
just
the sound a sound effect being a punch
line i love that dude i love that
and i think that's a big note that i i
take away from the special in general in
that clip
is
don't take any moment for granted
like he could have been oh they kept me
up all night i had to go to the door
10 times or whatever but literally he
made every single knock like a moment
which then became a punchline
yeah just the examples i mean and i mean
what he did was a power of three right
it was just he gave you three examples
of how cracking that door was
right
each one
felt a little different until you got to
the punch line which was basically the
[ __ ] never stopped it was pretty much
like that all night long but that's what
i enjoyed about like just the
specificity of going deeper into that
but just yeah just the doo doo doo or
him going to the door like i don't even
think i don't know if you caught this
but like he changed his voice because he
was 10.
who who's there yeah
yeah yeah
to try to make it sound like it was a
you know like he was an adult
not and he wasn't supposed to be doing
those things but that's what made it fun
yeah he used his voice really well too
where he he can be a little soft and
then he can get real loud and big with
it too like he uses just every
and i think people watch this and are
like oh that's all you do with
storytelling but he even said in the
podcast it's like he spent
and i hadn't heard any we've interviewed
over 400 comedians i hadn't heard any
other comedians say this but he spent
like a year
working on
specific skills so it's like we talked
about him sitting down because i think
the first time i interviewed him his
comedy central special just came out
and he opens it up like he does this
special where he's literally just
sitting in a chair he's like what's up
like this is his comedy central debut
and he's just like
what's up
and it i like but it i forgot where i
was going with that what were we talking
about
you were talking about how he's worked
on skills oh skills so like he worked up
to that stage presence he's like for for
like a year i worked on just having the
mic in the stand and he's like for a
year i worked on just sitting down like
he
he worked on a specific skill
for an entire year to really hone his
act and sharpen each of these skills so
as you
see comedians like ali performing at
this high level
like learn from it but also don't think
oh i can i just go out and do all that
at once it's like okay i want to tell
more stories
step one could literally be
what are all the possible stories that i
could tell that are unique to me like
ali he's doing stories only he could do
what are stories only you can do
and then
write it out not trying to be funny like
ali said write it out dry as he says and
then go back and insert the punch lines
like it's
this this comedy game dude is so
incremental it is so
one show at a time
one rep at a time and then in like
10 20 years that's why for
all the all the like comics that are
popping right now like i've heard most
of them say like
you don't even really know what's going
on until 10 years they're like you're
literally for 10 years just like a
chicken with your head cut off you may
think you know with certain moments but
he's like 10 years is really when comedy
starts and i can tell you someone
12 years in the game and really with the
pandemic
i mean more like 11 like without you
know if we're not counting the pandemic
12 but the pandemic took us all back but
i i can say like i'm just now starting
to feel like
oh
maybe i can try this like i'm still
trying to figure it out and learn but i
i can tell you someone doing it over 10
years it really is like that 10-year
mark is where you're getting now
comfortable enough on stage to then be
like okay let me start applying all
these fancy bells and whistles it it
literally takes that long tony bologna
just said 10 years so if you're not
ready for that
you know
you know go viral on social media and
you're good but if we're talking about
just stand up that's the game dude
that's the reality of it
yeah for sure yeah yeah i mean and it's
just a commitment to the art right it's
just yeah
into the art form figure out what you
want to you know i forget who's who has
said it before but like figure out what
you can improve on
like every time you go up
yeah we've talked about this and just
like every set
have an intention of what you want to do
for the set what do you want to
accomplish for the set right like
uh
my show this weekend
i want to uh have fun like that's the
thing i'm focused on have fun with this
set and it's like yeah have an intention
with every one of your set but also like
there's been weeks where i'm like all
right
this week i'm focused on not laughing
after my own joke
just because i need to practice not
doing that right yeah it's okay
sometimes but i just want to be like oh
let me just see if i can do it without
it and
it worked you know i'm saying but it's
like
adding these other skill sets right
there's a week where i mean like there's
like maybe a couple of months where i
was just like
no set list we improv and everything
and you just see what happens
or like a month where i go nothing but
crowd work see what happens like just to
like i mean
and
all those people that you know everyone
that does comedy at this high level
they've tried so many things i've seen
so many comedians do stories do
one-liners do act outs they try so many
things and then they own it on where
their voice is
on like what is it that they're really
good at and then they just keep doing
that kind of thing so yeah so you just
got to try it
yeah setting i i i like to set a single
goal for a set and early on that those
goals would be like remembering to
breathe on stage and a story i've told
before
is literally like
at an open mic it's like a monday open
mic at a bar with like 12 comics you
know and that's like it's just like open
open mic you know
and um if
oh dude and actually
to give you context for this open mic
here here's actually a photo i have on
my desktop of this open mic so here's
the open mic i'm talking about
is that hole in the wall this is a hole
in the wall
this is a real open mic that i used to
do all the time
and and um what i would do is honestly i
would set a goal of like i want to focus
on breathing this set and then like i
would literally like audibly breathe on
stage like i would say a line and then
audibly breathe on stage
and then i would just develop the the
pacing that way but it's all just one at
a time
that's one of those open mics and i'll
tell you this i think i've told you this
before i remember doing that open mic
when i first started doing comedy and i
remember i'd gone up like maybe like
three or four times to other places and
i did like fine it wasn't like great but
i did fine it was like five minutes man
i went to
i went to a hole in the wall
like i had this five minute tight set i
got through that set in three and a half
minutes yeah
i went in the car i cried all the way to
the house
[Laughter]
and all i was thinking was like he gonna
cry in the car i did it
and we all go through those moments dude
as comics we all go through those the
worst thing i was that's why when you s
when i s when i saw it i was like
flashbacks
yeah you had a little ptsd from that
open mic yeah
and speaking of things to work on i
think next week our goal will be to have
timers um because we've done it again
like three weeks ago we're like we're
gonna start doing timed segments and
then this one we're like ali sadiq blew
our minds we just need to talk about
this
and um
yeah so it's 5 50. uh but ryan's in here
good to see you ryan and uh zeb and
jacob over in the you in the uh facebook
group and teresa good to see y'all
um
tyler over here yeah oh and dubs talked
about yeah him talking with ali about
doing one thing at a time standing in
place
then staying with the mic stand behind
you and then elevating to seeing in the
stool and then the chair yeah all
incremental yep oh incremental yeah yeah
all right you want to joke feedback real
quick yeah let's um should we jump
straight to joke feed back here
yeah let's do it we can probably do like
two before we do the other thing
bet all right so let's do and i'll have
a timer for this one
i'm gonna have a timer for this one one
second
okay well don't
don't auto start the timer there we go
okay
so we had jordan uh lee funny comic leaf
funny here you go
all right
shaggy has really ruined being a dad for
himself whenever he catches his kids
doing something wrong they have the
greatest alibi it wasn't me
all right
i get it
um
i think the only thing would be
it's very much like observational about
something
else in the zeitgeist versus making it
personal and giving your own take on it
[Music]
that's number one it's like maybe shaggy
influenced the way
i've been a dad so whenever my kids
catch me doing something wrong i'm like
it wasn't me
kind of thing
yeah yeah i like that too of him
personalizing it
um
yeah and then it's just relying on you
knowing shaggy so like there's a there's
a specific reference there that the
whole joke hinges on which is
it's uh
it's not always great
to i'm not saying it's wrong but if you
a lot of people need to remember shaggy
from it was me middle school i think
yoshi you know that was probably college
for him but um
hilarious
um
who just said that shaggy and scooby-doo
line
someone just said i thought it was
shaggy from scooby-doo
yeah i mean you have to like that's what
people are gonna think if you don't make
the reference like
that specific um
yeah that's people are just gonna think
it's
whatever
their name
reference is that's what's hard about
those jokes
yeah if you don't know it makes it hard
yeah oh and that was a
hot breath og jody carter as well so
thank you jody for chiming in there my
friend
um yeah like i like what you said let's
sneak in one more joke here before we
get to our flowers and tony's talk about
pablo francisco a few times yeah i would
love pablo would be great on here talk
about
just a force of nature on stage
incredible
that's what i think about pablo s
about to say pablo escobar pablo
francisco's comedy it's very fast and
furious yes for sure
who was rick mccarthy i'm seeing here
um
a little about me and my mother
a little about me my mother is actually
a roman catholic nun obviously she gave
up the calling for family i'm guessing
that's where the curse comes from
that or the booze
booze
[Music]
a little about me my mother's actually
roman catholic none always give up the
calling for family
i'm guessing that's where the curse
comes from
that are the booze
there's so much missing in context here
yeah it's like a it's like a confusing
phrase right now
yeah like we need a joke structure set
up punch you know set us up to think in
one direction and then the punch line
creates a surprising second direction
yeah i think it's where the curse comes
from but i think there's an assumption
that we know what the curse is oh
yes
clear about what curse you're talking
about
is it the curse from being a catholic is
it the curse from calling as a family as
a you know being a mom
or is it some you know it's it can't be
the booze because that's what you're
comparing it to so
yeah it's just not clear
maybe he's the curse
you know maybe rick is the curse him
being born is the curse you know um
yeah
but yeah there yeah there's just
it's first for like an overall joke note
it is like joke structure is set up and
punch line you're setting up the
audience think in one direction and the
punchline creates a surprising misdirect
um that's where that's like joke
structure but the joke premise
is kind of your north star that's like
your thesis that's like
what is the joke about what is the
nucleus of this joke and right now we
don't even know what the premise is so
it's tough for us to even give you a
specific note so ask yourself what is
the premise what am i trying to say here
and that'll help you to find the joke
structure
sure and then also you don't need like a
little about me
right just go with mother like it's just
you're just it feels like filler and
sometimes that's one of the hardest
things is you know something i still
struggle with is
using too many filler words but i
recognize that one way to get rid of
filler words at least for me
is to say the joke out loud
and then like once you say it
then you'd be like oh did i really need
those words to actually say it on in in
like writing it looks great but when you
say it like ah i didn't even need that
record yourself and then you'll be like
probably didn't need it for the joke
like you said right
every word matters yeah does a little
about me matter for this joke exactly
yeah that's a good note because ryan
actually had asked uh he he wants to
break the habit of like the no and gnaws
and the yaz all those filler words after
jokes and stuff so hopefully that helped
out ryan there and anyone else watching
yeah
nice
um
oh snap we're about to give flowers
let's get flowers to smooth the king he
said yo since we're giving flowers i'm
so grateful for hot breath you guys have
helped me so much through my first six
months of
[Music]
comedy thanks fam
smoove the king i love love love love
love hearing that
yeah
hot breath versus ouchy
so yeah we are giving flowers who are
you giving flowers to today yoshi
you know my flowers uh
it's probably very uh similar to last
week uh
it's because i just i love it when
comedy community is like just
gives it up for each other my flowers is
going to be to the world series of
comedy
these
are
just super
like
like it goes this very big festival uh
you know i'll say you know from my
perspective this is my third year doing
it but like there's moments when it
feels pressure filled moments when it
feels like uh like i can't believe i
didn't move on or all this other stuff
but at the core of it
it's just getting comics together to do
their art but also exposing us to
uh
you know bookers exposing us to people
who know the craft exposed us to like
venues that haven't seen us before and
so you know i went there last week i did
uh did my thing and um
but just like the community of all the
people that just work at the festival
but all the comedians that were there
like you know exchange numbers i was
like hey if you guys are ever coming in
town and for me even as a outside of
being a comedian i'm also a booker and
i'm a producer so i got to see people
who i would love to see on stages that i
produce so if they're ever in town like
oh hell yeah they would love you at my
show
because i've now seen you and then just
to remember like
comics and comedians are where you're
going to get a lot of your bookings from
so yeah my flower goes to world series
of comedy for this week shout out
shout out to world series of comedy uh
we've had both of like the
basically the founders there we had joe
lowers who really started it and then
jason who also was very involved at a
high level now we've had both of them on
the podcast we we taught a class with
jason i mean
jason uh you and i would do like a type
5 accelerator we would help comedians
develop a five-minute set in a month
and um i i even called before i shot my
dry bar special i i scheduled a session
with jason because the feedback he gives
and the care he has
to help comedians it
um yeah those guys are really doing it
to help comics and i've i've been to a
lot of festivals and i always enjoy the
world series because it is like comics
first i've booked more work
from doing world series than probably
any other festival so um yeah it's yeah
shout out to you
uh that's a good shout out there yeah i
agree with that for sure
yeah
and the show was incredible in the
and you know shout out to mccurdy's in
sarasota oh man i've heard that place is
amazing
amazing venue dude
they packed that show out on wednesday
thursday friday and saturday oh i love
that on a wednesday it was packed out
like i was just like what is happening
of course it was like a seven because
you know those people have to go to bed
but it was so great
it was still such a great show
yeah
shout out shout out to our world series
of comedy we'll see you later j legg
the crowd definitely looked like your
grandparents you mean uh but it was
great
it was like
that's rex
and uh my flowers are gonna go to
patrick seaman
this guy is not
he has a good sense of humor too patrick
has been in the hot breath verse
he's one of the ogs
and he's always wanted to get on stage
and then he finally
did it this past week he did uh hot
sister in
sandy bernstein you know um you know
that show i went up to maryland and you
know got a standing ovation on
um
patrick was at that show
and then um we kind of like set a goal
for him for the next month to do his
first stand-up show and sandy put him on
his show
and um he really showed and gave a lot
of love to
the hot breath verse and how helpful the
community and the classes have been to
help give him the confidence to get on
stage so
i just love hearing that and sometimes
we forget you know that we're
interviewing a lot of well-known
comedians and
a lot of the people that like the show
haven't even been on stage yet so that's
a big hurdle that i kind of forgot about
being in the game so long that that is a
big hurdle to overcome and patrick
actually did it so
[Music]
salute to patrick and sandy for giving
them the opportunity first step after
you write is to get on that stage yeah
and then you i mean i i always say
you're gonna know whether you want to
stay in or not stay in after that first
time
and no matter how it goes no matter how
it goes
either it's kind of like that runner's
high that they talk about either you you
enjoyed it
or you did not exactly
yeah
and it's just starting you know uh a lot
of comics will go and watch for a little
while and then get on stage or if you
don't know how to find a show you know
there's zoom shows of course but then
you can just google your city
and
uh comedy open mics or you know what i
performed at music open mics i performed
at karaoke shows i performed at poetry
open mics like
i i just performed where there was a
stage in a microphone so if your town is
too small or whatnot i'm sure they have
something karaoke something that you
could get up at you know trivia night
you could even try there and ask the
trivia host if you could do a few
minutes you know it's um
yeah while he's taking a break he's just
like can i do some comedy yeah yeah
and like you said your flowers last week
were those facebook groups about coming
to
specific cities if you just search the
city
on facebook you'll probably find a
facebook group where they have their own
community and shows that you can do
[Music]
cool
oh oh uh man he said
can you please repeat the name oh
sanders said can you rename repeat the
last name of jason jason roland i'm so
sorry
r-o-w-l-a-n-d yes roland and i may not i
may have just said joe and jason so it's
joe lowers and jason roland are the um
the guys over the world series of comedy
yeah oh
nice okay
very nice all right
so can you do a little joke feedback do
you need to run
no i can yeah let's do it
okay
so a few jokes here
oh and jody had a good tag for that guy
my mother was a nun she gave it up for
me
so that's why god has cursed me
oh yeah so do you see joke structure
he's kind of saying the same thing but
more in like a joke structure way nice
yeah yeah yeah i see that
i like that
oh and sandra said please do a podcast
on comedy festivals and what value
comedians can get from them also which
festivals are must do
yeah i've got a few questions about
festivals so i think that is irrelevant
and um that is a good topic
that um we could probably dive deeper
into
um
interesting yeah yeah that's a good idea
sandra
so let's see
ju we had lee funny we had ryan
oh rick
let me see
i think
this may be
is this mike no this isn't mike mar
i have three oh i think this is ev
valentine which
i met up with zeb
uh while up in chattanooga so salute to
uh zeb shout out to him he was
there we go he was hosting for uh dusty
slay
up in chattanooga so um let's see zeb's
joke here who read the last one i don't
remember
i think you did i'll read it okay uh
i have three kids and my wife wants a
fourth for three months we've been
trying a lot to get pregnant but we've
been unsuccessful i haven't told her
but six months ago i got a vasectomy
um
okay
that feels more like a confession than a
joke that does that seems yeah
so
i like i love how personal this is
uh
i like the details in it
but i think
the surprise element that you got the
vasectomy
feels obvious
i think what i'm trying to figure out is
if there's another way of saying that
in a more surprising way
yeah i mean maybe just getting to it
quicker i mean i have three kids and my
wife wants a fourth
but i don't have the heart to tell her
i got a vasectomy or the fourth child is
a vasectomy or that we we should name
the fourth child vasectomy
yeah that's funny i don't hate that
yeah
uh yeah i have three or even like i have
three kids and my wife wants a fourth
i don't have the heart to tell her
that after
kid number three
i got a vasectomy like just like play
out what you did based on it's like
after
after seeing kid number three i got a
vasectomy or like after experiencing kit
number three i got it was like you mean
like just
raise the stakes just a little bit
yeah and getting to it quicker i think
that we edited out a lot of that filler
to get to vasectomy as well
yeah nice
nicely done there though zeb thanks for
sharing buddy
um
oh erica said i usually write after
watching y'all but now i'm gonna watch
ali
nice
i'll tell you now it's it's i tried
writing after ali like just story wise
and there are some stories that i've
been wanting to and i'm kind of a mix of
stories and like i don't i don't want to
say one liner but like it's quicker
jokes
but yeah it was definitely like
inspiring just to watch him
and the detail that he puts into each
one of those stories is so good
bro it's just another i remember
this titus i saw him on youtube
something on youtube where he said
like it was either titus or it might
have been jeff foxworthy was talking
about stories because he did stories
um
just saying you know just write out the
story just say it in like the most
mundane way no it was roy woods who also
said that too
on the podcast yes on the podcast we
just lose track of all the sauce
oh
the names you just the names you just
dropped
of like was it jeff foxworthy or like no
it was like oh it was roy wood jr that's
right that's it's like
you're talking about roy jr and this
walmart thing
say what
this walmart i had juneteenth stuff
yeah i saw kevin stage post about it not
roy wood what happened
they attributed it to roy wood jr they
basically said they took it down because
really junior called him out on it but
it was like he was just like i was just
making a tweet about how ridiculous it
was so when they stopped the juneteenth
stuff
i don't yeah i think they stopped it
yeah but like
they attributed them stopping it to a
tweet from roy jr whoa
i didn't say anything like he was like
that was it originally me i was calling
out somebody else who brought it to my
attention but it was just funny just
like because you know comedians are like
ah this is hilarious here's my take on
it
wow that yeah yeah that was i mean
it was it was a bit much there was like
all these shirts and plates and it was
ice cream
yeah it was it was a lot
i mean yeah i mean i look like
christopher columbus and even i was like
bro they are colonizing juneteenth right
now
sam walton
what's goodie fam
uh it was wild dude monetizing
juneteenth
speaking of juneteenth dc ranch just hit
us with a super chat
i don't even know what that has to do
with showing showing love that's what i
don't know why i said speaking of
juneteenth but i hope she doesn't take
what if she took the super chat back
she's like oh never mind oh racist face
facing boy
thank you for that hit her with the
shareholders thank you so much
dc rants we can now go tell our wives
that we made 4.99
doing this 4.99 an hour split between
the two of us plus taxes
and youtube fees
nah that's love
shipping and handling yeah
no that's real love there dc we really
appreciate that all of it adds up and
really does help so we appreciate that a
lot thank you so much there dc
um
oh and i think she she uh she posted a
joke
so
let's get to dc's joke because she did
uh she hit us with that super chat now
so
she she got it in two lines i think
uh i'm single in 43 and it's hard to
find a new person
my requirements have changed
now you better come with a good
education good relationship
with your mother and family also i'll
need you to provide the results of your
latest glucose levels and sleep apnea
test results
[Laughter]
it's actually a pretty good joke yeah
it's just wordy but it's pretty funny
like i get it i like
the fact that
the punch line is that you also want to
know the glucose level and the sleep
apnea test results which is very
powerful
i think it could just be
tightened up to know you better come
with a good education
family relationships
and i'll also need your glucose levels
and sleep apnea tests
yeah
yes yeah that's good just like
convincing it a little bit there
yeah
but otherwise i like it really
honestly i would love to hear more if
you're 43
i would want to hear more
like a personal experience of you
struggling if you're 43 and trying to
find a new person that's like as we talk
about ali's unique stories and unique
experiences he talks about
i like this is a funny power of three
silly joke but i'd like you to get more
real about this you know being 43 and
single out here in these streets when
these new dating apps i can't even
imagine like what that hustle's about so
get more into that i think would be
super interesting
yeah yeah yeah i like it though she said
a tag but i mean i think just editing it
down to be tighter like we said
and then the tag would be like i think a
real life example go ahead
who knows what a tag is i think it's
what is a tag it's a question
oh
oh yeah yeah i mean that's that's yeah
that's a very valid question i mean a
tag is like i think jerry corley also
calls them like a topper as well but
it's like another
punch line connected to your punch line
so it's like
i have a joke about
being drug tested and making and paying
eight dollars an hour so it's like
they paid me eight dollars an hour and
drug tested
and then the punchline is like both
so there's the punch line both it's like
eight dollars an hour the job should
include drugs so it's like the punch
line and then the tag is that it should
include drugs so it's like an additional
punch line
that's
based off the first punch line
if if that did i describe that
yeah
it's just an additional joke that
doesn't need an explanation that doesn't
need another setup it's basically you're
adding more punch lines think of it a
tag is more punch lines
to an already established punchline yeah
i like you said it's all connected to
that initial setup like it's another
punch line for that setup good call
yep
nice oh and that's why i wanted to add
the part about punching you in your
sleep
oh last part of the joke i'm too old to
be punching people at night while
they're sleeping
oh
i like that
yeah yeah yeah
43 at night while they're sleeping yeah
yeah yeah
that's funny
that's funny because that's what you
were dealing with
being 43
is you've got people who have sleep
apnea because i i'm assuming that that
happens with people who are older
that's really funny like the things
you're worried about dating when you're
older honestly dc i think this is part
of a bigger bit about like
you
dating when you're younger versus dating
now and like what you're worried about
when you're young is like getting caught
by their parents and now you're like
now you're worried about those sleep
apnea or something
yeah it's you're worried about a sleep
machine uh a sleep apnea machine in the
room yeah yeah yeah
very nice
i'm with it dc
thank you for sharing oh and steve poger
in here you're not late only we only
started at five so you're only an hour
15 late no worries steve
um
no you're good fam thanks for jumping in
here
um it's always good to see your pretty
profile picture in here steve
um
we had some other jokes up top didn't we
that's what i was looking for so we had
that
zebs
something about getting sits at 30. i
don't know what that was i think this
one's mike marr
i believe
oh and jacobs is the zits at 30. but i
think this one's mike marr
and i think jacobs is after i wait did
you read who read the last
i think you read the last one okay
i graduated from one of the most
prestigious art schools in the world the
other day someone asked me how much i
make i said that's kind of personal well
if you must know i'm an artist and i
make stick figures
just got it
uh
um
[Music]
you just got it
yeah it's stick figures like six figures
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
silly goose i'll give you a silly goose
that's definitely a mike mar joke there
[Laughter]
i think if you put s on it though and i
think with mike's the delivery if he
like pauses
before
i make six figures it's like a silly
kind of if you pause before it and then
i think sticks
put the s on sticks
it makes a little more obvious
yeah
um
yeah and i think you can like edit it
down it doesn't need to be
as wordy
uh
like the if you must know like i said
that's kind of personal
i make sticks figures
and just end it like that yeah or even
like as a graduate of a prestigious art
school
i'm proud to say i now make six figures
a year or something or my yearly income
is sticks figures
something like that
the more you say it the funnier
because i'm so funny right
no the like the more you say it like
just
just i can imagine like
just more
like the more you keep saying six
figures
the funnier the joke is
there you go
i'll take it can i have that joke mike
can i
[Laughter]
oh
nicely done
um tony baloney my my youtube videos get
no views the only way one of my videos
can ever go viral is if they're infected
with malware
okay
um
this would work at a security conference
like a cyber security conference i love
this
yeah
because i know what the all those things
are right so it's viral but instead of
actual disease it's more like i mean
instead of viral videos it's viral
malware
um i think it's just about context
whether people would get this
or not
uh i actually wonder if you want the
other viral the only way that people can
go
my videos could ever go viral as if it
had coveted
versus
the
malware cyber security because that
feels like more in the zeitgeist of a
topic so that's my only thought but not
bad but kudos for ending with the
punchline you know what i mean like so
he ended with malware so he actually i
think the joke if you know malware like
you said
um
i think you may be able to get the
reference so structurally i'm with it
tony yeah structurally it's there yeah
it's just more
is everyone gonna get what malware is
exactly yeah and jacob said that's a
nerd joke that i liked yeah jacob liked
that one
um
speaking of jacob here's jacob's joke
i'm still getting zits at 30. i watched
my wait i'm sorry i read the last one
i'm sorry
you didn't
did oh you read the last one
yeah oh okay well then never mind i'm
not sorry
sorry not sorry
all right
i'm still getting zits at 30. i wash my
face with the best soap walmart has to
offer i swear every day i wake up with a
new constellation
i can check my horoscope by looking in
the mirror
okay
and for context jacob said he hasn't
been on stage yet he's still he's a fan
of the show but hasn't been on stage yet
um
so just i think
one i like how personal it is you
getting zits at 30 it's something unique
to you jacob that i think people can
relate to you know which is really
interesting
um
i almost feel like
the best soap walmart has to offer in
itself
could be the punch line you know i don't
understand while i still get zits at 30.
i'm using the highest quality soap from
walmart or something like that you know
showing that
and it is clever the constellations i
can check my horoscope by looking in the
mirror
is also clever
but i think the joke could be i don't
understand why i'm getting zits at 30
i'm using the highest quality soap from
walmart
i think that's it
yeah
it's the other piece doesn't add to the
joke
it's too convoluted it feels like two
separate jokes it's like it's also it
feels like an example of
like trying to be more clear than clever
so it's like oh my zits are everywhere
like a constellation so i can check my
horoscope by looking in the mirror so
i love the creativity behind it but for
joke structure it's kind of just like
what is the setup punch here
but nicely done
yup
nicely done there jacob um
that maybe
we already read one of tony's
um
oh lord
we missed her last part of the joke no
we didn't miss it
we said it
um
so
smoove to king
all right
all right my dad had five kids four baby
mamas
he took a paternity test at 75 for a
mystery daughter it was a
and he was 100 the father i showed up to
meet her with diapers and baby formula
but she was 54 year she was a 54 year
old stud
it seems really personal if this is true
my dad had four kids five kids with four
baby mamas i mean if that's true dude
then i would love to hear more about
that in general
um
he took the paternity test at
75 for a mystery daughter and was 100
the father i showed up to meet her with
diapers baby formula she was a 54 year
old stud
huh so
i feel like we're not getting the order
to get the punchline so the punchline is
obviously that
you showed up with diapers but she was
too old because of the mystery daughter
we're not getting the context of where
you are in this mix like are you the
youngest
like where
you and me like
how do you fit in
to then meet the 54 year old i'm not
sure if the 54 year old stud
helps any yeah i mean maybe if she's 54
then like instead of your sister she's
like your auntie
yeah something like that you know
yeah yeah
yeah
i think that's probably better
i i'm with it i'm with it and i think
the final one
we have is jody carter sweating is
losing weight but i sweat when i sleep
so i don't need to go to the gym
i just need to go back to bed
tag can i get a wake-up call in 20
pounds
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't hate it
i really don't hate it um
so instead of the gym i go to the bed
yeah i think one thing just to enhance
the joke is just say scientists say
to uh if you're sweating you're losing
weight yeah i swear i sleep that way
there's some context to the statement
so i don't need to go to the gym i just
need to go back to bed that's so funny
yeah i like it though
yeah that's solid yeah i like that
scientists say sweating helps you lose
weight
luckily
i sleep i sweat in my sleep so instead
of the gym i go to bed
and then can i get a wake-up call on 20
pounds
yeah
oh yeah jacob liked that one he said
that's a good one jody yeah
i like it honestly and i think it fits
with jody's um
persona as well oh he said he will add
that good stuff jody nice man
i love it
uh
is that all of them
nice
uh dc asked if that was an okay tag what
would i look like getting a domestic
violence record because i punched
someone snoring while they were asleep
so like uh one thing about
adding questions don't add questions
just say the statement is much easier
rather than making it like a rhetorical
question
because if you ask a question
you don't necessarily like want the
audience to answer
but that's what you're asking them to do
when you ask a question
even though it's a it is a rhetorical
just say
just
change that
question into just a statement i don't
look great punching somebody who snores
while they sleep i like that yeah yeah
yeah
it's like make it about you
yeah instead of just asking just saying
it and yeah i agree that punches
harder
but really yeah i do like that just
making that little adjustment there
yeah yeah
all right should we land the plane
let's land it let's land it we went over
about 30 minutes um but
yoshi is not only a father but he's also
a soccer coach so um
he does take valuable time
from his children being a father figure
to do this so um we will not compromise
his families
but uh thank y'all so much for hanging
out with us you know we do this every
single tuesday
right here at 5 00 p.m every single
tuesday so please join us then join us
at five to get joke feedback as well and
not an hour 20 later
um
but uh we do appreciate y'all please do
subscribe to this youtube channel and
share it with your fellow comedians i
will be back live on this channel
tomorrow at 10 a.m
to do our
fellow friends
write 10 contests we do here every
single wednesday at 10 a.m where we get
a new word and write a new joke and then
at 5 p.m i'll be doing my live q a on
this youtube channel so
nice and if you're in the dallas fort
worth area i will be at the dallas
comedy club this weekend on the 28th and
the 29th
your boy's a headliner out here
trying man we trying to be out yet man
we love it well ladies and gentlemen the
hot breath the verse subscribe and share
this
and we'll i'll be back tomorrow at 10
a.m we love you all so much
yeah i appreciate y'all
bye